quando eu comecei a atuar na política há
as pessoas perguntavam para minha mãe
aqui em dois córregos pertinho daqui de
bauru
ando aqui que seu filho faz e ela falou
nem está envolvido com política
parecia que eu estava cometendo um crime
e é difícil de dizer é difícil de
explicar a ela e à minha família que é
uma família simples aqui do interior que
a política era algo diferente do que
aquilo que ela estava sentindo as capas
de jornais as revistas os telejornais e
tudo mais mostra o contrário e eu fui
criado numa família em que o futebol
política e religião não se discute a e
não se discute e as infelizmente ainda é
em muitas famílias da nossa sociedade no
nosso brasil
mas quando eu conheci vestibular
e quando a gente presta vestibular gente
sabe exatamente o que a gente quer da
vida
eu prestei a administração pública
administração de empresas
imagem e som e psicologia e por uma
beleza do destino de deus eu consegui eu
passei a administração pública da unesp
de araraquara
sou o primeiro da minha família a
iniciar e terminar o curso administração
pública de da universidade pública e nas
primeiras semanas eu entendi uma coisa
quanto o estado impacta a vida das
pessoas ea maior parte das pessoas não
têm idéia ou dimensão disso eu falei
para ele ter um negócio interessante
aqui eu quero estudar mais
eu quero aprender mais sobre isso e
comecei a dedicar toda a minha graduação
e entender um pouco mais o impacto e
como estado funcionava a história da
relação social e da da conclusão de que
precisava o juiz de um estado para
administrar as relações sociais ea
política sempre esteve ali como um dos
aspectos do estado que influencia o
estado e automaticamente influencia a
vida das pessoas mas sempre vista com
muito preconceito por mim
não nesp lá em araraquara a gente
decidiu criar um programa um projeto
chamado prefeitos paulistas dos quais a
gente trazia um prefeito do interior pra
falar sobre sua vida pessoal para falar
um pouco sobre quem ele era
da onde ele vinha ou ela era de onde ela
vinha o que ela gostava de fazer isso
foi muito importante pra mim e pra minha
turma pra nossa turma começará a
desmistificar a imagem do político o
político com uma pessoa que almoça e
janta que se alimenta um representante
do povo que é eleito mas que não o
glamour da política mas que existiam
pessoas por detrás da política e pessoas
muitas vezes muito interessantes e
depois da universidade para desgosto da
minha mãe eu decidir atuar na política
porque eu comecei a perceber que as
disfunções que haviam nas relações
políticas
elas impactavam estado que impactaram
diretamente a vida das pessoas e as
pessoas não tinha ideia disso
e aí eu me deparei com um dos conceitos
mais incríveis da política
política é a busca da felicidade do
coletivo no coletivo
esse é um conceito de aristóteles a
busca da felicidade do coletivo ou seja
todas as vezes que estamos fazendo algo
pensando no coletivo e mesmo algo que
seja muito individual
nós estamos fazendo política
infelizmente algum momento da nossa
trajetória como sociedade a política foi
seqüestrado na vida da gente
e parece que só quem faz política são os
políticos são os partidos políticos são
os eleitos os congressistas
então eu comecei a me dedicar a mostrar
para as pessoas que todos nós somos
fazedores de política e que eu vim falar
hoje tem a ver com isso
depois da universidade eu me juntei com
um grupo de pessoas dos mais diversos
partidos que também estavam na reflexão
que não era abordada pela casa
mia das disfunções reais da política das
políticas da política institucional no
nosso país e nós começamos a discutir
como era uma nova forma de fazer
política
hoje pra ser representante ser candidato
no nosso país é necessário se te um
partido político os partidos políticos
então detém o monopólio da disputa
eleitoral do estado democrático de
direito traduzido para se disputar
eleição precisa estar no partido
político em seu monopólio dos partidos
acontece que quem já participou de algum
partido político sabe que os partidos
que detém o monopólio da representação
do estado democrático de direito
normalmente na sua maioria não são tão
democráticos assim ea experiência de
estar no partido político é horrível é
machista é preconceituoso é autoritário
compostos basicamente por homens brancos
e mais velhos e isso pra mim passou a
ser uma questão muito forte e nesse
nesse movimento de discutir novas formas
novas regras novas relações e eu conheci
pessoas que vinham de lugares diferentes
que o meu pessoas que tinham na política
uma forma de sobrevivência e resistência
pessoas que precisavam atuar na política
para esclarecer para as outras que elas
podiam ser quem eram elas deveriam ter
as mesmas condições e igualdades que
outras pessoas e aquilo foi me
encantando ainda mais e entendendo que a
política era a busca da felicidade do
coletivo nós somos nos conectando com
outros mecanismos e hoje nós temos uma
geração de pessoas que está assim
preocupada com a política está atuando
na política para a transformação da
nossa sociedade e que infelizmente
muitas vezes não são o que é ou não é o
que é para aparecem nos jornais porque o
que vem a notícia são os
sensacionalismos e infelizmente as
coisas negativas
uma geração inteira parte da geração que
ajudou a conquistar nossa democracia
depois da redemocratização
parece que se sentiram tão importantes
que agora precisavam tomar as decisões
sobre os rumos do nosso país e abandonou
parte de uma geração quase que toda as
ao mercado e à sua própria sorte na
formação política
isso contribuiu para o nosso
entendimento de que só eles parecem que
podem fazer política mas não é verdade
a política é algo nosso e de toda a
sociedade
nosso cotidiano é político e nós fazemos
política no nosso cotidiano
vejam a escola ensina matemática
geografia ciências biologia mas
infelizmente não ensinam alguns
ferramentais básicos da discussão e da
política do ser vivo que é escutar com
atenção falar com intenção e dialogar
há discussões o diálogo com diferente
com plural a discussões que nós
tratávamos às vezes na decisão de um
grupo de estudo às vezes dentro da nossa
família isso é política estamos fazendo
política no nosso cotidiano e é preciso
que a gente desperte para política é
preciso que a gente nos entenda com
fazedores de política é preciso que nós
nos compreendendo como seres humanos que
estamos habitando um coletivo seja nossa
família a nossa sala de aula seja a
nossa universidade a nossa cidade o
nosso estado o nosso país
o nosso planeta nós somos seres
políticos por excelência e como tal
precisamos formar para isso precisamos
estar atentos às nossas ações
precisamos estar atentos à nossa relação
com o coletivo
quando eu disse que eu fiz parte de um
movimento que começou a discutir sobre
novas formas de fazer política
eu ajudei a fundar um partido político e
depois de um tempo a fundação deste
partido eu assumir junto com marina
silva como
o porta voz nacional do partido
assinando como o presidente de partido
mais jovem da história do brasil
isso significa muita coisa mas o
simbólico era que havia ali um jovem de
25 anos de idade
como presidente nacional de um partido
no lugar aonde só homens brancos e mais
velhos habitavam e nas reuniões com
gilmar mendes por exemplo ministro do
tse presidente à época do prédio do tse
em que ele convocava todos os
presidentes
lá estava alguns achavam que era
estagiário do partido outros falando só
esse povo aqui é muito maluco pra por um
jovem desse dessa idade pra tá aqui com
a gente mas é impressionante a
possibilidade de poder dialogar e falar
para aqueles presidentes e para algumas
mulheres que há também conseguiram
também assume com o presidente do
partido que um dos grandes problemas da
representação no nosso país são os
partidos políticos e que nós precisamos
quebrar esse monopólio da representação
apenas com os partidos políticos ao
provérbio que alguns acham que falam que
a chinesa outros indiano mas que diz o
seguinte que o planeta ele não nós não
herdamos o planeta dos nossos ancestrais
mas nós pegamos emprestado das próximas
gerações se política é a busca da
felicidade do coletivo e à busca da
felicidade coletivo são decisões tomadas
no coletivo por indivíduos que embuídos
um senso de coletividade tomam suas
decisões
as decisões não são para o passado mas
tem a ver com o nosso futuro tem a ver
com o podemos ser uma civilização e nós
precisamos nos reapropriar do sentimento
e da da presença de que somos seres
políticos do nosso cotidiano mesmo
aquela pessoa que decide não ir mais
votar ou votar nulo está tomando uma
decisão política muito radical de
entregar aqueles que vão votar bom
escolher um representante
qual vai ser o rumo do nosso país
quando alguém decide votar em uma pessoa
porque ela é engraçada ou fala coisas
que nossa como assim uma pessoa fala
desse tipo é uma decisão política e nós
precisamos abrir os olhos das pessoas
sobre isso
o que está em jogo na política nas
decisões políticas nas decisões públicas
é o rumo do nosso coletivo chamado
brasil ou do nosso coletivo chamado
estado o nosso coletivo chamado cidade e
nós precisamos ter responsabilidade como
indivíduos e um coletivo e eu estou
falando disso porque hoje a minha mãe
entende um pouco mais do que estou
fazendo na política e e em outro dia
inclusive ela veio me perguntar sobre a
síria eu fiquei super feliz com a minha
mãe tá procurando saber sobre outros
problemas que não os da coletividade
dela é direta
agora a minha provocação hoje para todos
e todas que assistem é como nós nos
vemos como fazedores de política como
nós podemos reapropriar o zimbábue de
ferramental para diálogo político que a
escuta que é fala com intenção que é o
diálogo para a tomada de decisão como
nós podemos contribuir no nosso
cotidiano sendo quem somos
fazendo o que fazemos na construção de
um coletivo mais feliz e mais parece
parece blaser mais um coletivo que tenha
uma visão de futuro
eu sou cego estava eu tenho 28 anos de
idade só ativista política administrador
público ea minha missão aqui é deixar
essa mensagem para vocês é preciso
despertar para a política é preciso que
nos preparemos para a política porque há
uma geração inteira está ocupando cargo
de tomada de decisão e nós precisamos
entender que sejam as empresas sejam as
organizações não governamentais ou seja
em cargos administrativos do nosso
estado
nós tomamos decisões que impactam o
coletivo e se nós não estivermos
preparados sensibilizados para
compreender o impacto na nossa ação seja
no cotidiano da nossa vida seja nenhuma
empresa seja do governo ou seja num mg
se nós não estivermos preparados nós não
estamos preparados para devolver o nosso
país nosso estado nossa nação eo nosso
planeta em melhores condições para as
próximas para as próximas gerações
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]